today we are all Poe Dameron learning
the Empire is back because somehow The
Witcher 3's technical issues have
returned when the game launched in 2015
there were several massive bugs plaguing
players at the time that eventually got
ironed out with patches and updates now
that the game's next-gen update is out
it's like we're living in 2015 all over
again as this new version of the game
seems just as problem latent fortunately
it seems if you're playing the update on
Console like myself you're for the most
part in the clear although I have had
some weird minor visual bugs like
texture pop in and issues around the
photo mode but on PC it's a different
story wobbly frame raids strange HUD
glitches and outright crashes are
affecting even those with the beefiest
of rigs fortunately on PC It's
relatively easy to roll back to the
previous version of the game if you're
on Steam all you need to do is right
click on the game in your library click
on properties then baby datas and select
the classic beta Branch some redditors
suggest turning off some optional
settings such as Ray tracing before
rolling back to see if that helps
specifically with frame rate hitches CD
projekt Red has officially stated that
it is aware of the issues that it is
actively looking into them and will be
putting out another update as soon as
possible like I said if you're playing
on Console like the PlayStation 5 you
should have a relatively bug free
experience but in case you want to give
the game some time in an abundance of
caution new games are being added to
PlayStation Plus's extra and premium
tiers to keep you busy after taking the
year off WWE's 2K franchise returned in
2022 in mostly fighting form with WWE 2K
22 re-emerging with a strong foundation
and an overhauled gameplay system
however PlayStation is slightly cheating
by calling this a December Edition as
unlike the rest of the lineup that will
be added to the 2 two bonus tiers of
PlayStation Plus on December 20th WWE
2k22 won't be available until January
3rd 2023 on December 20th though fans of
the Far Cry franchise are in for a treat
both Far Cry 5 Primal and New Dawn will
be coming to the service as well as rgg
Studios games Yakuza like a dragon
judgment and Yakuza 6. remember these
games are part of PlayStation Plus's
extra and premium tiers December games
for its base essential tier which are
available now include Mass Effect
legendary edition biomutant and divine
knockout head over to gamespot.com for
the full list of extra and premium
titles if you're looking for something
to play on PC epic games has announced
that it's a seminal Arena shooter Unreal
Tournament 3 is being rebranded as
Unreal Tournament 3x and will be
releasing as a free-to-play shooter on
platforms like steam the epic game store
and Gog with cross a save and play
however along with that awesome news is
the not so awesome news that a bunch of
epic games will be losing their online
services rendering some of them such as
battle Breakers completely unplayable
the list of games include Rock Band 1
through 3 and unreal tournaments 2003
and 2004. these titles will have their
online services shut down on January
24th 2023 head to gamespot.com for the
full list of affected games and then hit
the comment section of this video and
tell me how amazing Witcher 3 is look I
know it's having troubles but it's my
favorite game of all time so just could
you could you just tell me it's really
it's really great and that geralt's
really cool just like
please